la France a toujours été
particulièrement ciblée par la Russie
puis l'URSS et de nouveau par la Russie
je pense que c'est pour plusieurs raison
c'est-à-dire que au moment de la guerre
froide dans le bloc occidental
évidemment vous essayez de trouver les
failles les plus évidentes il se trouve
que pendant la guerre froide sorti de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale euh peut-être
que la cible la plus facile était la
France euh peut expliquer ça par
plusieurs raisons évidemment la sortie
de la deuxième guerre mondiale on a un
parti communiste qui était très fort on
a un
américanisme aussi au sein des élites on
peut vraiment expliquer ça de de
différentes manières moi j'aime bien
rajouter aussi le le le problème
généralement de de du fait Queen France
au contraire du modèle anglo-saxon on a
une presse qui se targue d'être une
presse d'opinion d'être une presse de
combat ben forcément ça encore une fois
c'est l'opinion est bien plus facile à
infiltrer c'estdire que cette habitude
français de débat et cetera ça donne des
opportunités c'est ça en fait ça donne
des opportunités formidables pour faire
passer les messages que vous vous avez à
faire passer parce que la la guerre de
la désinformation finalement vous
rappeliez l'époque de la guerre froide
c'est effectivement vieux comme le monde
on avait un peu oublié en fait c'est ça
bah on avait on avait même totalement
oublié je pense à la sortie de la guerre
froide il y avait quand même cette idée
que pu c'est une idée aussi c'est c'est
c'est la fin de l'histoire la fin de
l'histoire de Francis Fukuyama
c'est-à-dire que maintenant que le
communisme est une théorie he tout à
fait c'était la théorie de Francis
Fukuyama qui stipulait que maintenant
que le communisme est mort c'était le
triomphe des démocraties libérales et
qu'on allait tous finir par marcher main
dans la main dans le soleil couchant
avec le marché unique pour nous unir
tous dans la paix et la prospérité bon
il se trouve que 30 ans plus tard on on
mesure quand même l'erreur et le le
l'erreur de diagnostic qu' a eu à
l'époque et et je pense que oui ça a
contribué à nous faire oublier cette
menace cette guerre de l'information qui
s'est jamais arrêté elle malgré la fin
de la guerre froide et l'éclatement de
l'URSS la la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement sur les ingérences
étrangères elle explique que la Russie
est le seul seul État à avoir érigé en
doctrine officielle la manipulation
d'information avec l'objectif
d'affaiblir
euh oui alors c'est pas il y a il y a
toujours plein d'objectifs différents ce
que ce que raconte la doctrine russe
quand on plonge un petit peu le nez
là-dedans ce qui est pas très agréable
je je recommande pas c'est assez austère
mais ce qu'on remarque quand même depuis
2016 notamment c'est qu'il y a surtout
dans les opérations de de dans le
domaine informationnel comme ils
appelleent ça des visées qui sont
d'abord défensives avant d'être
offensives c'est-à-dire que du point de
vue de la Russie du point de vue du
kéblin on mène des opérations dans le
domaine informationnel pour protéger
notre propre modèle de l'influence
extérieure néfaste donc concrètement en
langage traduit de l'influence dégénérée
des Occidentaux qui essayent de faire
passer des valeurs démocratiques chez
nous alors que quand même c'est quand
même plus sympa quand il y ait Vladimir
Poutine au pouvoir ou ou des modèles de
société donc que les Russes ne veulent
pas en fait c'est ça eu que le Kemlin ne
veut pas en tout cas ne veut pas alors
là ce que vous racontez notamment c'est
que la propagande russe bah elle passe
il y a différentes façons hein de
d'influer de de d'influer sur sur
l'opinion publique et un des canals un
des canaux plus exactement c'est bah les
youtubeurs absolument moi j'ai pas fait
un livre sur la désinformation c'est
c'est souvent une petite confusion que
généralement on fait mais qui est normal
c'est c'est pas un livre sur la
désinformation c'est un livre sur ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque de l'Union
soviétique les mesures actives donc dans
les mesures actives ça regroupe
l'intégralité des moyens qui permettent
de modifier de l'information ou
d'arriver à tirer le narratif dans votre
sens donc il y a la prop e mais il y a
aussi le recrutement d'agents
d'influence il y a l'utilisation des
idots utiles et il y a la fabrication
défut quand on prend ces quatre ces
quatre modes d'action typiquement les
youtubeurs c'était une tentative de
recrutement d'agents d'influence
c'est-à-dire que on a des entreprises
russes qui d'ailleurs ne se présentaient
pas comme des entreprises russes qui
sont allés voir différents youtubeurs en
France pour leur dire on va vous
proposer plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros afin de faire de la
désinformation pour que vous puissiez
faire de la désinformation il dit au
youtubeur on va faire la désinformation
il se présente pas comme ça non il
concrètement ça à quoi ça ressemble en
fait je suis par exemple une youtubeuse
très influente comment l'entreprise
russe vient vers moi parce que c'est pas
forcément non plus ça peut être une
entreprise privée hein c'est ça ah mais
c'est c'est de toute façon toujours des
entreprises privées toujours des
entreprises privé vous avvez jamais
c'est très rare on imagine toujours ça
on a tendance à avir la main du
crémeelin un peu partout mais faut quand
même garder en tête que Vladimir Poutine
et le crèmeelin ne sont pas les seul à
avoir des agendas à à à faire faire
voilà servver en Russie euh là pour le
coup c'était notamment un youtubeur qui
faisait de la vulgarisation
scientifique absolument qui a été
approché par mail par une entreprise du
coup qui se prétendait anglaise et qui
lui a dit écoutez on veut faire une
campagne informationnelle sur les
vaccins parce qu'on était en pleine
période de pandémie on voudrait que vous
diffusiez ces éléments de langage que
l'on vous fournit et quand il prend en
connaissance des éléments de langage il
voit bien que c'est de la désinformation
qui tendait à dire que le vaccin de
pizer était absolument une catastrophe
et que que au contraire le vaccin de
spoutnic des rues c'était quand même pas
si mal que ça donc la ficelle était un
peu grosse et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que aujourd'hui personne n'est tombé
dans le panneau lui lui lui tout de
suite il s'est ah lui tout de suite il a
révélé il a révélé le photose
directement publiquement sur le réseau
social Twitter Ré et on lui proposait
combien là c'est les sommes d'argent
n'étaient pas indiqué dans mes souvenirs
mais on parle quand j'en discutais avec
lui c'était plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros d'accord de toute façon
et ça pouvait être oui à mon avis ça
pouvait aller jusqu'à 50 plus de 50000 €
pour faire une petite vidéo alors pour
un un youtubeur qui
refuse combien accepte combien accepte
bah alors ça c'est une difficulté qu'on
a c'est que tant qu'on n pas accès vous
et moi de toute façon au compte bancaire
des gens la plateforme elle-même YouTube
ne sait pas ce genre de chose les
arrangements qui sont pris comme ça par
mail entre une entreprise et un
producteur de contenu de toute façon
sont un secret y compris pour la
plateforme qui va héberger les
contenus aujourd'hui quand même je suis
assez optimiste de ce point de vue on a
on n pas eu d'opérations qui ont eu
l'air d'être un grand succès je pense
que ça n'a pas marché aujourd'hui après
est-ce que ça continuera comme ça à
l'avenir c'est une autre question est-ce
que YouTube lutte contre cette
désinformation il sont pas tellement
intérêt quand même à à colpter de la
désinformation ah mais non ils ont
absolument pas intérêt ils ont des
obligations légales aussi donc et et
puis sur si ils ont une charte quand
même que tout le monde signe quand il
décide de créer du contenu sur Youtube
ou même d'envisionner il y a quand même
cette idée non il lutent quand même très
activement contre ce genre de phénomène
alors après avec les moyens qu'ils ont
eux aussi encore une fois une entreprise
américaine n'a pas prise dans les
communications personnelles qui sont
faites par mail entre une personne qui
est en France et une entreprise qui
prétend être basée en Angleterre euh
autre canal autre canal de de de pour
pour agir pour influer c'est les la
messagerie cryptée telegram euh vous
parlez de du CAN de la de infodéfense
hein c'estes 28 chaînes créées au début
de de la guerre en Ukraine vous-même
vous avez vous êtes proposé comme petit
propagandiste hein absolument je suis
devenu une petite main de la
propagande mon livre ah ben alors ça s
passé alors toujours pareil hein de
c'est toujours extrêmement décevant
parce queil y a pas beaucoup de compéten
non plus en face il y a pas beaucoup de
vérification euh donc en fait j'ai juste
envoyé un message à la personne qui
disait être tolier du canal qui m'a dit
qui m'a fait passer un entretien
d'embauche des plus sommaires parce que
la seule question qu'on m'a posé c'est
est-ce que vous parlez russe vous avez
dit oui j'ai dit oui grâce à Google
Traduction globalement et ça a suffit
pour que je me fasse embaucher et que je
devienne une petite main de la
propagande alors A VOUS avez pas pris
votre vrai nom vous avez non bien sûr
non non bien sûr ils nont pas cherché à
vérifier qui était je sais pas comment
vous êtes présenté mais il y a pas eu à
priori de vérification il il y a pas eu
un appel même ne serait-ce que un appel
pour vérifier si votre niveau de rus
était à la hauteur ou pas ah non mais
absolument pas et puis de toute façon
moi j'étais mis dans une position où en
tant que francophone il savait que
j'étais francophone de toute de toute
façon natif il il m'avait mis à la
vérification des traductions donc en
fait je je regardais l'orthographe s'il
y avait pas des fautes d'orthographe qui
étaaient d'accord c'était des textes qui
avaient été TR qui avaient été traduit
du russe au vers le français vers le
français et moi mon rôle consistait à
voir s'il y avait des fautes
d'orthographe ou pas d'accord et si
c'était relativement intelligible c'est
ça oui c'est ça et puis euh je garantis
pas que j'ai toujours été un très très
bon employé d'ailleurs ça durait combien
de temps cette infiltration ça a duré de
de ou TR mois quelque chose comme ça
quand même ouais avant qu'il se rend
compte du potoros parce que je rendte
mais parce que tout simplement parce que
je suis rentré dans ce canal avec un
collègue qui s'appelle romain mielkarek
journaliste au Monde qui est journaliste
indépendant et qui a justement fait un
article pour le journal Le Monde et
quand il a publié finalement son article
avec toutes les informations à
l'intérieur ça a été un petit peu paniic
à bord et ils ont viré à tour de bras
les gens il y avait des tapes dans le
canal en fait c'est ça voilà ils ont
découvert à cette occasion qu'il y avait
des tapes dans le canal donc moi j'ai
réussi à tenir un peu plus longtemps que
les autres juste pour observer un petit
peu la panique des gens dans le canal
qui n'étaient plus très
très en sécurité à l'idée de s'exprimer
et qu'est-ce que vous avez observé avant
que ce soit révélé c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionnait bien qui était bien
organisé ou c'était un peu amateur en
fait non alors il y a il y a deux
niveaux c'était extrêmement bien
organisé dans le sens où si vous voulez
dans l'architecture qu'il y avait à
l'époque je sais pas si elle a été
conservée depuis d'ailleurs mais il y
avait quand même un espèce d'état major
qui était composé de personnes russe
auquel nous on nait pas accès il y avait
un responsable du canal pour le canal
francophone mais aussi une vingtaine
d'autres langues avec d'autres chefs de
canal à chaque fois euh et en fait il
recrutait des volontaires c'est-à-dire
que nous on était évidemment pas du tout
payé il recrutaient des idiots utiles
littéralement c'est quoi un idiot utile
c'està-d ah bah c'est quelqu'un qui
décide de faire le travail de
propagandiste pour pas un rond en plus
quoi c'està-dire que sans être payé
parce qu'il croit c'est ça en fait oui
littéralement mais c'està-d que mais des
gens mais c'est ça ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on sous-estime énormément en
France mais euh le
discours la propagande russe a une
portée aussi en France il y a des gens
qui quand Vladimir Poutine tient des
discours à la télévision qui parle de
l'Occident dégénéré euh par les LGBT euh
qui dit que de toute façon le grand
remplacement est une réalité et cetera
euh et que de toute façon la dégénéré
sence et que nous au moins on est on est
un vrai bastion de de de la chrétienté
euh il y a des gens pour qui c'est un
écho aussi en France il y a des gens qui
se retrouvent dans ce type de discours
et ces gens qui se retrouvent dans ce
type de discours n'hésitent pas
eux-mêmes par la suite vu qu'il y a une
connivance idéologique à aller porter
eux-mêmes à aller amplifier ces mêmes
discours partidéie il sont sur la les
mêmes valeurs en fait des idos utiles
euh la France a mis du temps à à
réaliser cette cette présence cette
propagande russe c'est récemment hein
qu'elle s'est réorganisé c'est ça c'est
c'est même très récent euh je moi je
pense que c'est une originalité de mon
livre c'est-à-dire que quand on parle de
désinformation russe ou de guerre
deination on parle toujours de ce que
font les Russes en France moi ce que
j'ai voulu faire dans la deuxè moitié de
mon livre c'est absolument com la France
réagissait face à ce que font les Russes
donc je suis allé taper à la porte de
l'intégralité de tous les ministères qui
étaient concernés j'ai même des services
de renseignement qui m'ont ouvert leurs
porte avec qui j'ai pu échanger
justement à ce sujet et une des
premières questions que je leaurais posé
à tous c'est
alors à quand remonte en fait la date de
la prise de conscience elle remonte à
quand et en fait les réponses sont très
différentes en fonction des gens à qui
vous posez la question ce qui fait que
ça ça c'est du coup très difficile de
vous donner une date précise quand vous
recoupez en fait c'estàd que les
macronistes la première heure eux ils
vont vous dire ah bah nous on avait tout
vu avant les autres donc 2016 avant même
qu'on arrive au pouvoir on était déjà
très très fort sur le sujet là c'est les
Macron leak c'est voilà donc en plus il
y a eu les Macron leak du coup pendant
l'élection présidentielle 2017 donc je
pense que leur réponse était quand même
hautement contestable surtout que
derrière Emmanuel
Macron a quand même été a quand même une
ligne politique qui était de dire il
faut renouer les relations avec Vladimir
Poutine il faut normaliser les relations
entre la Russie et l'Europe donc je
pense que c'est au final très
contestable quand les macronistes vous
disent on était au courant avant tous
les autres au regard de la ligne du
président de la République euh le
ministerère des Affaires étrangères lui
évoque Samuel pati généralement le
ministère des armées évoque pourquoi
Samuel paatti Samuel paatti parce que
après la mort après l'assassinat de
Samuel Patti il y a eu de grandes
campagnes de désinformation et visant la
France et notamment je me rappelle d'une
campagne pakistanaise qui visait à faire
croire aux gens sur les réseaux sociaux
que la France tatouait les petits
enfants musulmans dans dans qu' tatouer
les petits enfants musulmans dans ce
pays ce qui évidemment une absurdité
totale mais ça c'était une des campagnes
de désinformation qui venait du Pakistan
et du coup le ministère des Affaires
étrangère mais la mais quand même le
curseur au moment de l'assassinat de
Samuel pati justement après ça euh le
ministère des armées lui il parle de
2018 c'est le la date où il y a eu la
publication d'un rapport euh qui avait
qui avait un petit peu marqué à l'époque
qui était un rapport conjoint entre le
CAPS et l'IRSEM le Fing Tang des armées
euh le temps de du dénis de la naïveté
tout ça c'est derrière nous ça y est
enfin les
service vous faites laamou vous n'y
croyez pas vraiment je pense que les
gens sont tous très contents de dire que
ça y est c'est la fin de la naïveté je
pense que oui dans une certaine mesure
je pense surtout que le début de la
guerre en Ukraine de l'invasion du 24
février 2022 a marqué a remis un peu des
compteur à zéro ent voilà quand même
quand même on a arrêté les les idées de
vouloir remettre nos relations à zéro
avec la Russie de Vladimir Poutine je
pense que tout le monde a compris
aujourd'hui ce qui était le régime de
Vladimir Poutine alors après oui la fin
de la naïveté vis-à-vis de la Russie est
peut-être arrivé c'est pas dit que la
naïveté ne revienne pas dans un deuxième
temps d'ici quelques années hein
certainement mais même si on a compris
ça pour la Russie reste encore tous les
autres c'est-à-dire qu'il nous reste
aussi la Chine l'Inde typiquement qui
est un nos alliés stratégiques sur qui
on déteste dire du mal mais enfin l'Inde
mène des campagnes de désinformation
aussi qui sont très agressives en France
là sur tous ces acteurs là typiquement
je pense pas que qu'il a une fin de la
naïveté au contraire je pense qu'on est
encore en plein dans la naïveté et pour
la Chine c'est particulièrement
problématique parce que si on reprend
quand même les choses la Russie le PIB
de la Russie c'est 1700 milliards 1700
milliards de dollars annuels bon la
France c'est 3000 milliards de
PIB bon la Russie ça va c'est pas une
très très grande puissance contrairement
à la Chine qui est quand même deuxème
économie du monde où là on va rentrer
encore dans une autre échelle à l'avenir
et c'est très préoccupant qui est pas
encore eu justement cette fin de la
naïveté quand on parle de la Chine
typiquement et j'allais dire est-ce que
l'opinion publique c'est-à-dire dans les
milieux universitaires les décideurs les
chefs d'entreprisees est-ce que
finalement les gens ont ça en tête cette
possibilité autant ils l'ont peut-être
au niveau du du gouvernement des
ministères des différents ministères
mais voyez ce que je veux dire dans dans
les entreprises on on a ça en tête ça
c'est honnêtement ça fait partie des
enjeux et c'est des sujets qui sont
quand même de plus en plus prignants
quand même dans dans le débat public
aussi he plus largement on en entend de
plus en plus parler dans les médias ce
qui était pas le cas il y a quelques
quelques années quand même moi je me
souviens qu'il y a quelques années en
tant que journaliste indépendant quand
j'allais voir des rédacteurs en chef et
que je leur proposais des sujets sur la
guerre de l'ination bah il me
regardaient avec des yeux un petit peu
écartillés en Disano qui c'est ce fou
qui est pas sorti de la guerre froide en
fait quoi bah oui mais bon bon voilà et
et oui je pens je pense que la situation
a un petit peu changé notamment grâce
aux médias et la prise de conscience qu'
a eu dans les médias maintenant oui il
faut faut que ça continue et pas que les
entreprises ça il doit y avoir une prise
de conscience générale parce que la
guerre de l'information c'est quelque
chose qui touche absolument tout le
monde merci mer Nicolas Kenel je renvoie
les téléspectateurs à votre livre
passionnant allô Paris ici Moscou un
plongé au cœur de la guerre de
l'information vous faites des
révélations vous remontez des pistes
c'est passionnant à lire